[Musique]
elle a 20 ans elle est belle elle est
jeune elle fait du cinéma depuis qu'elle
a trois ans elle a déjà tourné 31 films
elle fanning et donc forcément un peu
agaçante mais surtout fascinante elle
est venue fouler les planches de
deauville afin de recevoir le prix de
l'étoile montante du cinéma américain
l'occasion pour jérôme bacquet de se
pencher sur le cas elle fanning une
trajectoire trop parfaite pour être
vraies réponses en images
elle est belle elle a joué dans son
premier film à 18 mois et à 20 ans elle
a déjà david fincher jj abrams et le
clan coppola son tableau de chasse avec
sa vie son ragots et son côté gnangnan
mézague la nouvelle égérie l'oréal et
nerveux presque tous les médias
boring elle fanning bientôt à la fiche
de gueule stone de mélanie laurent elle
fanning
tout le monde sait qui c'est mais
personne ne la connaît
beaucoup apprendre d'où vient elle il
faut imaginer les kardashian mais en
version non silicone et ultra chrétienne
elle fait partie de l'église méthodiste
des états unis donc voilà si parfaite
qui modèlent flash back
elle voit le jour en 98 dans l'état de
géorgie
[Musique]
et comme kylie la demi soeur de kim son
père est athlète de haut niveau
sa grande soeur dakota quatre ans
apprentis stars et sa mère joyce apprête
à tout lâcher pour gérer leur carrière
ils m'ont dit ça quand il très vite les
soeurs fanning s'impose tout signer en
mode paquet
d'abord en 2001 dans sa maille am sam
avec sean penn avant de doubler en 2005
mon voisin totoro
attention vous allez faire dents de lait
mignonneries devienne la marque de
fabrique de la fratrie qu'elle impose
alors sur tous les tapis rouges oh oh
attention ne pas confondre avec les
soeurs olsen de la fête à la maison dont
l'une s'est marié en 2015 avec olivier
sarkozy
le petit frère de nico j'aime les gens
qui s'engagent bref retour en 2008 elle
a 9 ans tourne sans sa soeur depuis cinq
ans fait 5h de balai par semaine
et joue pour la deuxième fois de plus
belle avec ses potes brad pitt et cate
blanchett dans l'étrange histoire de
benjamin button l sérieux hollywood six
jeunes tout ça ça vous a pas fait péter
un câble et pendant qu'elle
collectionnait les images d'oubari mort
au même âge collectionnait les ardoises
résultat la mairie font littéralement
pour cette petite croquettes bio et
gorgés de soleil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et en 2010 c'est la consécration sofia
coppola lui confie cléo le premier rôle
féminin de somewhere
dès lors pour elle tout s'enchaîne elle
joue dans super 8 de jj abrams dans
twixt de papa coppola ou encore dans
maléfique l'adaptation de la belle au
bois dormant au côté d'angelina jolie et
tous sont unanimes
elle a non seulement beaucoup de talent
mais aussi un super agent pas comme sa
soeur aujourd'hui dakota est retourné
dans l'agencé où sa soeur était advenu
amis et elle fanning qui est plus dans
le devant sur le devant de la scène et
qui appuient des premiers rôles 2016
nouveau tournant l'ado débarque à cannes
pour la première fois avec l'ultra
violent ni anne yvonne de nicolas
winding refn le real de drive elle a
tout juste 18 ans glacial et hyper
esthétique
le film reçoit un accueil mitigé mais
c'est mieux pour elle la fin de la crise
d'acné
c'est un peu la beauté froide qu'on a
envie de souiller du coup on la met dans
des rôles d'héroïnomanes prostituées
cannibale est en effet nymphomane dans
le film féministe twinning century woman
ancien accro à l'héroïne et ben affleck
petit pour son deuxième rendez
vous avec sofia coppola extraterrestre
punk avec nicole kidman en 2010 est
l'enfant chéri de l'amérique se la joue
trash et maîtrise à la perfection de sa
trajectoire
certifié 100 craquage à 19 ans justin
bieber lui abandonné en pleine tournée
son singe mali à munich 2018 c'est
l'année elle fanning
à tout juste 20 ans elle est l affiche
de pas moins de quatre films pour
peut-être trois rapport à celui qu'elle
a tourné avec woody allen pas vraiment
sûr de sortir hashtag wainstein tout ça
tout ça plie ce qui fait quatre ou trois
raisons de se remettre la mèche de
travail et sont retournés et danton gras
quel point elle est merveilleuse
notamment donc d'élever stone et elle
elle a 19 ans et elle a encore plein
d'envié elle n'est pas du tout blessé il
ya une scène dans une baignoire où elle
pleure il ya une scène sur un lit et
elle va retourner faire la et elle
n'a pas envie tout ça évidemment nenê
n'était pas prévu une heure avant donc
ça c'est quand tout d'un coup avant
d'aller manger il ya une demi-heure et
je vais la voir et lui dit et ce qu'on
peut faire cette scène qu'est ce que tu
en penses
et elle elle me regarde et elle a une
montée de larmes elle me dit vas-y lui
prête
voilà le week-end dernier l'enfant star
devenu grand recevait le prix du nouvel
hollywood au festival de deauville
nous on est rassuré en vue pas de borne
à l'hôtel à britney
[Musique]
mais plutôt une carrière saluer
d'honneur anna jodie foster est ce que
c'est facile de survivre à 14 ans et
demi dans le cinéma
je sais pas pourquoi ces bandits dont on
joue encore un goal des sports
[Applaudissements]